hey no no no no
no you're just a demon you're just a
demon
it's expired sir oh come on man you know
how many times i've been in and out of
this gate with that excuse me what's the
odds on isis it's about the vehicle sir
you want me to step out of here i'll
have him he's with ranger battalion
ranger battalion
i've been busting my ass to get my mind
and my body back into a good place i
need to get back in the game sir you
want to get back in the game prove it
sergeant rodriguez was a legend family
funeral sunday outside of nogales they
want his dog at the funeral you do this
and you're back in the game
she won't work with anyone one minute
she's good the next minute she's sending
three guys to the er what's up dawg and
you're gonna go on a little road trip
easy what are you so scared smell it out
[ __ ]
what is your deal man maybe just take
crazy down one notch
[Music]
no no no no
no you're just a demon you're just a
demon
whatever happened to you dogs you used
to be 11.
[Music]
hey
[Music]
you're so good how'd you make her get
out of your hand yeah i just talked to
her see she's just a noodle she just
knew so good
[Music]
you don't do anything else psychotic on
this trip maybe we can have some fun is
that a deal shaker
lulu is that you
good girl you give hugs now really lulu
gives the best hug you've never had a
lulu
no we don't we don't we don't exactly
hug
so you tell me that nuke was just as
messed up as louis i had to work him
every day for six months when he stopped
struggling that's when i realized maybe
i could stop struggling too
it's okay it's just lightning right
look at that
she's never slept in a nice bed before
ain't no shame in wanting a big comfy
mattress i was hoping you might have a
room for me and my little girl is that a
purple heart was she wounded um
yes she she was thank you for your
service
i've never seen this dog exhibit any
aggressive behavior before never she
loves people
[Music]
oh my god i can i can see
[Music]
you're definitely not the girl i thought
i'd be the tub with but
i'll take what i can get at this point i
guess
you